yeah well it's funny you know we drew
the play up and you know the play was to
get Nola in the pocket from Jamal and
the way they defend we knew they were
going to step up and I said Aaron you're
in the dunk work behind the defense as
he steps up I didn't imagine the behind
the back over the head pass you know
that that's just you know when you're a
young kid and you're watching NBA
basketball that's Magic Johnson you know
that's Pistol Pete marovic the guys that
just had this uh Pizzazz to their game
and nicoa can beat you a lot of ways and
that was definitely one of the best
passes I've seen him make and you know
after N9 years there have been a lot of
them but he continues to amaze